scaring up some Spirits at the Venetian
and in this case they're the kind you
drink Louis caputa from rosina's
cocktail bar is here to tell us how
they're celebrating Venetian the
Halloween there how are things going
Louis well it's always great to be at
the Venetian and the Venetian celebrates
Halloween better than anybody else on
the strip
the cocktail Collective which is the
Elektra Rosina both that the Palazzo and
The Dorsey at the Venetian so I was
going to make for you a holiday cocktail
today from the Rosina called the pumpkin
spice cutting of course there's pumpkin
spice in it right mandatory you have to
have this time of year so we'll just go
over real fast
so what we're going to do is we're going
to do a half ounce of pumpkin spice
puree uh-huh by the way that's homemade
oh
half an ounce of liquor 43
very tasty now is this only available
during the month of October as a matter
of fact it ends October 31st but after
that you can get ready for our Christmas
cocktail so be ready okay all right
we'll have you back to talk about that
one one ounce of espresso
so far we've got the pumpkin spice we've
got the espresso what was that other 43.
okay and of course you have to have
whatever your favorite brand of vodka is
which is which is your favorite no I got
a lot of favorites can't really name
them all yeah one and a half ounces
I already put the ice in for time
give it a good Shake
how long have you been at the Venetian
I've been at the Venetian 17 years they
take really good care of me so I try to
take good care of them holy cow that's
fantastic fantastic place to work no
better place than the strip oh my gosh
that's great and how's business been
business is booming I love it business
we're killing it at the Venetian I love
to see all the activity back on the
strip it's really good to see me too
super excited this again is called the
pumpkin pumpkin spice kind of heel now
usually we'll do it with a coffee bean
shaving but today I kind of wanted to
switch it up for you and do a little
cinnamon
all right just got about 10 seconds here
oh that looks good too all right so they
can find you where at the Venetian so
October 31st if you want you wanted for
Halloween
so you got football you got costumes you
got drinks that's the special Trifecta
right there it doesn't get any better
than that that's not Lewis thanks so
much for joining us Mercedes